liberal cities are getting rocked by
violent crime but one mayor is saying
fears are being completely overblown and
the right-wing media yes they're to
blame
you know there's a lot of noise
about what's happening in our city
you see it in the headlines often in the
right wing media they love to talk about
san francisco don't they
you see it on social media you see one
video take off as if it's telling the
whole truth about who we are oh you're
not
would you like to begin judge i really
didn't intend to say that i thought well
you know what she's not i'm telling you
right now she's not okay she's the one
who said how many months ago it's time
the reign of criminals who are
destroying our city it's time for that
to come to an end and it comes to an end
when we take the steps to be more
aggressive with law enforcement is she
schizo
you know at one point it was like black
lives matter we got to make sure you
know we they have social justice then
it's like the reign of criminals has to
end then it's the right-wing media's
fault no it's not read the statistics
that's all i have to say and you know
what i was in san francisco not that
long ago and i was i was afraid and the
tenderloin district people are dying all
the time because they're doing cocaine
not the cocaine kills them but because
of the fentanyl that they're putting in
the cocaine that's coming from china in
an undeclared war as it comes through
the border and by the mexican cartel
that's all i have to do
i'm glad we went to you first judge
you're right about that comment she made
i forgot about that that was a great
point what would you like to say in
response to the judge passionate
commentary
i'm mostly in agreement
and i think that'll yeah it's it happens
and i would say also that a lot of
liberal leadership is an agreement we
talk about we're all here in new york
city we have a mayor that got elected
running on a tough on crime
agenda with a criminal justice reform
component to it which i think is
basically where everybody wants to be
certainly in the post uh george floyd
murder era and i think that what gascon
is saying in la and what london breed is
saying in that particular statement is a
bit of an outlier and the biden
administration has been clear you know
from the beginning we're not talking
about defunding the police we don't
think that this rhetoric is helpful and
if you look at the people in leadership
with clyburn uh
biden obviously kamala harris they're
all saying this is not how we see things
so why did london breed talk about the
right wing media
because she's grasping for straws is it
gasping gasping for air and grassman for
straw there are both
both biden and kamala harris ran on
getting rid of cash bail so that's the
central problem here in new york city so
let's not dismiss oh and by the way they
couldn't stand up and say uh riots are
bad stop burning our cities until the
poll numbers turned against them it went
on for months until they stood up and
denounced the violence it was happening
in major cities across the country i
want to point out real quick
george gascon was actually the police
chief in san francisco before he toddled
on down to l.a
appointed by appointed by gavin newsom
and then he was appointed by gavin
newsom then the mayor to be the district
attorney of san francisco so this
dangerous liberalism the pro-criminal
anti-victim
uh stance is like um
general herpes it spreads and you can't
see it and you can catch it it winds up
in your city and there's really no
treatment for it
there's no doubt someone not in not in
san francisco you watch
someone besides greg referenced do we
have val tracks for this kind of
liberalism go ahead greg uh gascoon uh i
i thought he was very helpful when he
was offering tips to avoid uh being a
victim of crime he said uh lock your
doors oh yeah
i'm gonna write that yeah here's another
tip avoid getting shot don't stand in
front of an incoming bullet i thought
that was helpful
i find that
i've said it before but it bears
repeating progressives deny
uh the brutality and suffering of crime
because they don't see it as a human
problem they see it as a political issue
that they must indulge uh to to placate
their base so they talk about criminal
justice reform rather than let's help
the victims right their base sees
victims as a reckoning for 400 years of
oppression although the last time i
checked elderly asian women didn't own
slaves or support jim crow so i don't
know why they're so silent about other
minorities being destroyed in the
streets
i don't want to get gross but i will
there's a dude that just attacked a
woman in the subway and uh by by
smothering her with his human feces on
her face
he boasted boasted that he was going to
get out he got out before she got her
treatment he was out
laughing about it how is that not like
assault with a deadly weapon with the
bacteria it's a chemical attack it's an
app i mean it's like but this is the
state of society right now a man can
walk up to your mother your grandmother
take a bag of crap shove it in her face
her eyes were burning
it was in her nose and he laughed and he
walked out how can you stand for this sh
you know what fouch she said about this
what a woman should have been wearing a
mask there you go she should have double
mask if she wore the the plastic the
face shield hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else